okay four people on the livestream
I should explain this as a design review
meeting for a feature that's coming in
the next version of Wolfram language
particular feature we're looking at
today is network packet capture so
purpose of this is to capture packets
from a network very low-level operation
it's kind of cool that one can do this
and get kind of a symbolic result that
one can compute with so let's give it it
well why don't we just give it a try let
me just actually run the thing so is
there a function now network packet
capture that has a GUI yeah okay so this
is showing me the network adapters that
I have and and Ken and Chris if you want
to comment on does this seem sensible to
you I mean I don't know what half these
things are there's a bunch of Annette
ports but I don't know what any of these
are I mean that's kind of what I expect
I don't know if those are the right ones
for your machine obviously but they look
like something that I would recognize if
I were managing the system okay and what
is like you ton zero what is that it'll
be the tunnel laughter yeah the one
question in my mind is are all of those
interfaces up on your system or maybe
we're showing interfaces that it might
individually be there but aren't really
up at the moment there may be yeah in
the comments on that it's possible that
is including ones that should be how
does it know which ones are online how
does it know which ones exist on my
machine versus which ones could
theoretically exist in this operating
system so it populates as list purely by
asking the Opera let's just record
something okay so I just was recording
from en 0 so that was a bunch of packets
380 two packets captured during that
time from en 0 so just for fun let's try
capturing from another interface here
anybody got a favorite interface in this
list okay no Chris do you want to
comment on this
nobody will do wireless hello if you've
got that one hello zero yeah that'll do
the loopback okay
what the heck is that what is that is
your loopback interface on your system
what is what is in the back interface
the system has a built-in sort of
virtual network interface to contact
itself it's a little bit odd but for
this all systems that do TCP have this
force like temporarily storing things
it's like a buffer local buffer thing or
something I mean it allows you to make
TCP connections without actually going
through Hardware network adapters it's
more of a if you want to do IPC over you
know Ethernet or whatever you can sort
of do it that way so one thing you'll
notice about about the info column is
there's no Ethernet hierarchy
specifically because because of what
they just said it doesn't go to the
actual Ethernet level and you know your
networking hardware it's the operating
system for ISO so just to understand
here these are ports
do we have an ident we we might have
somewhere else I mean what those ports
are assigned to maybe all kinds of
different things and so here why is that
lighting up why is that services for 97
is retrospect but hope I know we'd
killed retrospect that I wasn't using
retrospect anymore
good I mean it may not be on this
machine obviously it's it's just because
the services file says that's the case
doesn't mean that that's what's using it
now well no it could be a sir it could
be that we just discovered a piece of
horror on my um and yeah right um let's
see if I want to let's say if I say
normal of that okay so that's the actual
raw payload of that packet okay all
right so what we need to do so one thing
is that actual network packet capture
and um GUI
has that been fed to graphic design yet
if you click over in that
Crescent there's there's a design has a
scroll down there's another section for
network packet capture
if there it is well that's a rough
design that they have oh why
it's a and I mean where does it have
that pull down on things so I don't know
why it's roughly modeled after the net
train interface so I'm not sure why the
header is is there at the top maybe just
because that's what it was for net train
who is the designer who worked on this
fella did Billy Billy sure can join us
okay
all right Carla can you sit in darkness
okay
okay well I'd like to ask I mean that's
amusing but doesn't it burn CPU time and
so on to maintain this thing so the yeah
what we're doing is we're only going to
collect these statistics so we're only
displaying statistics about the number
of packets not when you're trying you
know dynamically display individual
packets and so this is modeled if you
open Activity Monitor it's about once
per second to I can say it's not
continuous okay fine
okay okay so there needs to be a pause
on a stop button just like an audio
capture right yes yes it should really
be modeled I think after audio capture
which we fin yeah it is somewhat I guess
the question then I have is should
should we include a pause is it useful
to be able to pause the capture and then
restart it you know keeping the same the
same data it makes sense for audio I
don't know if it's that useful for
Network packets I think it's useful
because I think you take an action you
pause the capture you futz around you
get ready another web web request then
you unpause the thing anybody want to
comment on that
it could be I think if it's easy to have
a pause we should have a pause way it is
easy to have a pause so we can have I
mean you can you can try out the pause
in the in the GUI right now the buttons
are functional on something start to
capture and pause it then restart it yes
when I just do him but am i running this
network packet capture no you're running
audio capture you have to abort it all
right that's oh I see that lined up the
hi um we're talking about the design of
network packet capture GUI you can't
work that audio capture thing and so
notice that you should click the X or do
something with the audio capture so it's
cuz it's running like modally like I
understand that I understand I
understand I'm just watching what it's
doing because I'm noticing that it is
running modally and that it has a
real-time display of audio volume here
whereas and I'm going to ask whether the
network packet capture thing has a
similar display of there are packets
going by but you're not yet recording
them to get what I'm saying
so that was a question that we that we
had is how I have it implemented right
now is that you know you won't see any
kind of dynamic activity until you click
capture and then it starts capturing
that I the reason I think that that's me
and I guess the same thing applies to
audio is that to get that stream to be
able to display anything dynamically you
have to start capturing and so it's kind
of like eager you know it starts you
know aftering things well do we want to
do that I mean with audio we've made the
decision that we are going to show that
even if we're not actually recording
because in the case of audio we have
these functions like this new audio
start recording function that can
essentially under programmatic control
so for example let's imagine that you
and systems people here please speak of
one of us makes sense want to say once
an hour capture five seconds of network
traffic
right for that how would you do that so
you could go ahead no I mean you you
probably wouldn't use network packet
capture you would probably use the
network what is it called recording I
can record now we're back recording okay
but we don't unfortunately have an audio
recording that is called the same I mean
then we would more naturally have an
audio recording um
could somebody see if we can find shadi
and let's just talk about the
correspondence between audio recording
and network packet recording in terms of
whether that makes sense I would say
that it does at least to the extent that
you want to have programmatic control of
starting and stopping the capture in
some cases not necessarily once an hour
like you said but you know if you want
to have the capture not running and then
kick off a process of some sort that you
expect to generate some traffic and then
start the capture to see if it does so
or vice-versa so that might be very
personal
alright so um Billy what we're saying
here that so there should be two states
of this thing the state before assuming
that we do not show like an audio
capture a real-time display immediately
which I agree seems kind of useless in
this case there needs to be a state
before capture was started a state
during capture and a capture after
capture was finished don't accidents
Billy yep um so why is it they after
after you just get the data okay fine
I'm wrong yes you're correct
okay so right now when we say network
packet capture yes okay so actually that
the states aren't quite what you think
they are so to speak so the first thing
is something like this where you're
selecting the network interface right
so the other thing is we're going to get
rid of that that drop down that I have
there and that's going to be argument to
to the function you know so this is the
arguments and network packet capture
like network packet recording is an
association where you specify you know I
want packets on port 80 or or you know
whatever and one of those things you can
filter by it will be the interface
you'll say interface goes to you know 0
you know big personally as kind of a
systems toughie I like this pulldown I
mean I hate to say that because I don't
know what network interfaces are on my
machine and how would I discover what
network interfaces are on my machine so
I added a dollar sign network interfaces
is it a dollar sign thing will kind of
change I mean if I unplug something can
it change you have to the network packet
capture so this the dollar sign function
is reevaluated ever like we go and ask
the operating system every time you
value 8 it so it is like wouldn't it be
more natural to say that what kind of
face is open close then if it's really
at every time
well I mean it's it's similar to like
dollar sign network connected right like
ok fine
alright ok I that that's reasonable
ok the ordering of these things is just
alphabetical any systems person want to
comment on that
I don't think order matters too much
every system is going to be somewhat
different in that respect and some of
them aren't even static between boots I
don't think spending what do you mean so
I mean there's not I don't know if
there's really any good canonical order
for the things so alphabetical is fine
ok all right and it's there I need go
ahead I was just gonna say I bet you're
about to ask about if there's a default
there's a dollar sign default network
interface which is how I was choosing
which one to select in the drop-down
is there amazing okay next question all
they're cooked names for these things um
or is it really just like it's you know
dev whatever it is or whatever the are
these are these dev things in a UNIX
operating system or they're not really
represented in in which is weird for a
UNIX operating system of course but it's
just a legacy thing they they really
haven't been you could probably get them
online it's in flash sis or something
somewhere but there's they're not
devices okay but so so there isn't a
name you know Ethernet zero or something
isn't naturally associated with the N 0
it's just the N 0 yeah on Windows I mean
you can you can tell based on the en
that it is an Ethernet interface and in
some systems you can tell particular
different types of Ethernet adapters by
the different names but it's it's gonna
be you know different on Macintosh than
life okay all right okay fine so if this
is the case then I guess I agree with
you that we just want that network
packet capture so then the interface
then is purely something which
presumably when it comes up it should
show you what you asked for
right right right I think and that's
what would show up if you clicked like
the plus button is you know if you
specify a network packet capture and
then Association of you know port goes
to you know if we do audio capture we're
not showing are we something that says
no there's nothing here that says audio
so I don't think we want that here
either
got what I'm saying Billy I'm here as
well my ratio okay um yeah shorty the
question is this is about network packet
capturing do you know anything about
this this is about looking at being able
to capture packets on um I was in one of
the previous meetings yeah I can yeah I
know okay so the issue is that there is
a function here called network packet
recording which is very analogous to the
audio recording function or the audio
record function and I think we need to
be consistent in those names and in the
yep so
to look at okay Network packet recording
what is the proposal here for how that
works it's just given a time there's one
it's a function page for this as well if
you want take a look at it yes the the
first argument is the time spec the
second argument is the the filter
specification
okay so shadi how does that correspond
to audio record their time specification
we would like to have as well in audio
recorder all you capture the problem why
we didn't make it an argument in all
your capture is that we decided to put
the file name as the output path in the
first argument but that function is
experimental for the same you know the
file name is kind of a crazy thing to
have that because most of the time it's
a UUID dump you know it's some kind of
UID file isn't it yeah if we don't
specify it yes
I don't think people I mean I think
let's let's just take a look for a
second at audio capture um so
you
okay I think that's crazy if I might say
so yeah I actually like to propose
something like the target location
option for I agree for a lot of these
functions that need a target location
well or alternatively I mean what this
is is really a file location which could
in principle be none if you don't want
the thing stored anywhere or it could be
a temp file which you want to have
cleared at the end of the you know at
the end of the reboot session mm-hmm I
like the file what did he call it file
location none if you go how do we get
the in core version if file location
none means in core but I don't think it
does really well why not
I mean five well look if we say
something like file storage so I wonder
whether we can get something from the
persistent value world you know because
there we've got a persistence location
right yeah that's a type of persistence
location which is a setting for let's
see um this is a
assistant object that has a yeah I mean
a persistence location is not a totally
stupid thing to have in the audio
capture thing to be able to go to that
same set of persistence locations does
that make sense
I mean it's the same thing you might
want it to be preserved across one of
these persistence locations
and I suppose I can also imagine with
this network packet capture that you
might want the same kind of thing so
look I mutate same thing like you want
to be able to store it to a file because
because currently it's entirely in court
there is no file processing it about
fine I mean that's Frank it's right yeah
for packets
yes I mean we might imagine that
sometime in the future but let's not
worry about that right now
so what I think we should do with audio
capture and I think there probably some
other things something like I don't know
maybe it's persistent storage arrow blah
blah blah and persistent storage our own
non means don't do it and persistent
storage our storage a persistence
location would generate a UUID to object
at that persistence location mm-hmm that
makes sense similar to that persistent
location I like that I haven't looked at
this in details but I like that we can
save it our kernel per front-end and so
forth yeah but that just specifies the
location do we have a persistence option
that can specify without specifying the
location saying whether I want it to be
persistent across kernel sessions or
front-end sessions and so forth yes yes
okay we're not just I'm just asking does
anybody know where this was being saved
Carla do you know where we're saving
this let me check but I don't think
there's a specific place as of right now
okay then we should I'll save it in the
core software engineering does anybody
know where that is let me check doesn't
have a folder yet that probably should
be doing a packet capture also for a
core software engineering it'd be great
if you could create a folder for that I
think I have one but not in this area in
a different area I'm pretty sure I have
one okay I will create one here although
I don't really believe I did can we look
doesn't seem to be under Ald but I
understand I don't think it is under
loyalty I think it was somewhere else um
okay anyway this is Network packet
capture packet capture one okay so
surely my point is yes exactly so
persistence location this is when you
say persistent value and you give a
persistence location it it is it is its
business to figure out how to name the
actual files that sit in that
persistence location okay right so
you're simply saying make it persist
across for example you know local to a
computer based on home directory which i
think is a great way to do this and it's
a it's some so I'm suggesting something
like persistent storage the expert on
this stuff is Roman and yeah maybe you
guys can can talk to him about that okay
let's come back to the audio recording
business so you're saying that you are
perfectly happy to have audio capture
and what what would audio capture having
a number mean it would be when you press
when you trigger it record for that
amount of time exactly when you start
recording records for and seconds but
now also it has the max duration option
which is doing the same thing so I mean
the so what I'm doing for Network packet
is there's two different functions for
this there's the capture function which
is you know your GUI and you know you if
you want to run it for you know five
seconds you have to sit there and wait
for five seconds and click it but how
can you be exact then probably you have
to trim it then if you want to be exact
and you know exactly how long you want
then use the other function network
packet recording which takes which which
requires you to specify a time okay 10
seconds or something like so I have it
split into two functions yeah which is
what's the plan for audio as well okay
can you specify a number of packets if I
want to capture a fifty or a hundred
packets from an interface that seems
like such a thing to be able to specify
yeah yeah I think that's useful I don't
know what the design for specifying that
that's think about that for a moment
okay I mean I can imagine things with
units but that's a little weird but I
notice also that for audio capture you
have
caPSURE running thing an analogous to
animation running exactly which Ian
should also consider for network I think
it can be yeah that that make sense yeah
we should ever capture running that if
capture running is true then you know
the GUI just starts running and you just
it's stopped now interestingly here
you've got an audio input device which
is the analog of the network interface
it's kind of interesting yes I mean it
suggests that you might want to network
interface option for network packet
capture but let's not worry about that
for a second so then okay so you have
got something where network packet
recording
analogous to audio recording would
default so there is an argument it seems
to me okay
so systems folk here is it more useful
to have a time or to have a number of
packets
I think it I think it's useful to have
both if there was a way to specify both
that would be really useful quantity
time time quantities and then the number
could be the number of tactics
possibly I mean packets are also I note
that I'm pretty sure there's a unit for
packets which might be used for food and
things like this yes there is
that I mean that may be a hope gosh
there's data packets also interesting
because I think packets is you know
packets of sugar and stuff like this
right um so we could do it with
quantities we could do it um I think the
problem is that we'd like to have
consistency because audio capture won't
have if a pure number doesn't really
have much that it could mean other than
time in seconds there's no sense of you
know I don't know what else it would
mean we do support quantity samples for
audio oh what do you mean quantity what
do you mean quantity 4,000 samples
interesting okay so look maybe the right
thing to do with network packet capture
is I mean we just have to decide what's
the default now this question about
whether I don't know what the difference
between data packets and packets is and
we should determine that from the units
team I mean I could probably figure it
out ah let's take a look I mean we can
probably figure this out but maybe we
don't need to do this right now
let's just go if we go um let's see if
we go to off alpha let me say 34 packets
Wow okay that's interesting it didn't do
anything
okay I mean that wasn't very useful but
at least it was it did interpret it so I
suspect that could be made to parse 34
packets could be made to default parse
to datapack low packets um so I was just
gonna say I think it should default the
time myself just based on what we
normally do with packet captures that
would be slightly more full more of the
time so I would agree with a default the
time and then have a method to input for
package okay if I had to run lengths to
get the count of package right
necessarily what about a method option
to network packet recording where method
goes to time or method goes to
horrifying I mean I think a better
strategy for that would be you know
something like this time goes to
whatever or packets goes to whatever but
I don't think that's I don't think we
need that I don't think we need to cross
that bridge I think that what we should
do is simply to use units I mean we've
got units let's use units so the action
items here are we need to talk to T
alpha units and get them to change the
default parsing in control equals for a
number and then packets Carla can you
take that sure
do you understand yes you and you
understand what to do yes okay um
then okay so then we'll look for the
quantity that is probably it's really
called data packets or we'll look for a
time quantity makes sense and and you
should also get from the unit's folk you
can what would probably do you can ask
for unit dimensions to find out if it's
a information if it's packets because
you also want to deal with if some crazy
person says to killer packets you want
to deal with that right we have unit
compatible Q I think fine okay all right
okay so then then I think that will work
for audio recording
and network packet recording so that's
all consistent makes sense okay let's
loop back to Billy and the graphic
design um so what we're saying is what
we should see initially is you do
network packet capture and all it should
show you is Kyle of a a go button is
that correct guys it should reflect some
of the information on what you've
requested and then show you a go button
that true seems pretty reasonable you
can go to my design folder I had been
working on something earlier today and
just a little bit now during the meeting
okay just like to talk to if you'd like
okay great
whereas
CSE yep and then tributed PNG yeah which
one the top one so you can ignore the
stuff on the bottom I'm still playing
around but at least we could doctor this
okay my only problem with that is it
looks like an opener mmm how do we make
it not look like an opener and I don't
think we know yet packets in packets oh
I see you're proposing that the
recording that the initial state of the
recording says there weren't any packets
so what'd you say I had to show that
there's this is like nothing's happened
yet but we're set up to go yeah and I
guess one thing that slightly different
about this is so you see the the middle
part where it says port 80 IP address
127 maybe you know whatever number that
is that would only show up if you had an
association argument its network packet
capture that the court goes to a e IP
address goes to you know whatever right
and also another comment about that is
you've got the network interface
specifier you've got a bunch of other
things there could be a fairly long list
in that association couldn't there be
there could be yeah you have a very
specific set of things you're looking
for yes is it useful to reflect that
list here or who cares Ameen I mean with
something mentioned you know you
mentioned that you wanted to have it
displayed like a table when we had this
meeting last time look you could
truncate it for looks if you wanted to
because if we're specifying a long list
of properties that we want in a packet
there's a good chance we've just done
that right right fairly repeated all
back if we don't have the room is is
there any scenario in which the
interface gets disembodied so to speak
shadi do you know about that for audio
capture is there a case where the audio
capture interface kind of separates from
the actual audio capture input line yeah
or if you if you actually make it
another input so if you start driving
around it
we are yeah okay fine fine that's true
but not with any other types of anything
well I mean you know you could have
something which is a input popup dialog
or something that contains just that
interface more you don't ever see what
it came from
if we wanted to do something like I mean
that would be something we've done on
purpose we could always fill it with
whatever state information was
appropriate at that time I think I don't
know if necessarily designing for what I
I think that the big edge case I don't
think it's gonna be fine so then then
then let's not have the information
there let's just have this now how do we
indicate a start button and by the way I
don't think that's our standard is this
blue the standard that we're using for
start buttons and so on that's what you
is using but is this the initial state
of audio to have a start button that
looks like that on hover I think on
hover it looks no the initial state is
gray on hover it looks like white blue
and then maybe it is actually yeah look
look look look this has a red record
button
nothing like that blue more like what I
would expect to tell you okay
so Billy I don't see why I mean the only
problem yeah I mean the the thing that's
nice about this is it gives you the time
that it's been recording here right
which we need here as well and by the
way if you're giving a packet number is
that the packets in packets out packets
well it's so I mean the this we just
basically mock this up from what our sex
does with Activity Monitor I don't know
I mean I think that I can you know
introspect to figure out which packets
were coming into the machine versus
going out yeah well maybe it's
interesting I don't know this system
okay listen but okay we've got several
different moving parts here one is in
network packet capture or rather network
packet recording you are saying let's
have a way to say get such-and-such a
number of packets okay so then the next
question is is that bulk packets both
ways or is that you know counting input
packet incoming packets to go what I'm
saying Orpah counting
going packets so unless we then break
the specifier for what we're asking for
they're into some Association right
there that says no go ahead and say so
what Wireshark does Wireshark doesn't
actually make that distinction
Wireshark just says packets per second
just as here's the total number of
packets you've got and counting packets
that's what I would expect to see but I
can't say for sure what they're doing
over here yeah the main reason that we
just have the in versus out distinction
there is because you know we were this
morning we were looking at activity
monitor and OS X and that's what
Activity Monitor shows I am perfectly
fine and I think it would be very
logical to just say you know number of
total packets we've recorded packets per
second and not make that direction you
know I mean it is relevant you know when
you are looking at you know debugging
Wi-Fi or something it's highly relevant
how many packets are coming back and how
many packets are going out I would yeah
I mean it's useful information I don't
necessarily mind having it if there's
another one of those things if there's
room for it you know that's great okay
but that's okay so then what we're
saying is the two things that should be
in the initial interface are it's going
to say zero because that's time zero and
zero packets
that have been recorded um so roughly
what we're going to need to say is um
you know in the interface there's gonna
be a red button and it's then going to
otherwise say you know there's gonna be
the button there whatever it looks like
they whatever our red button looks like
um together with then somewhere it's got
to say zero what is it going to say zero
zero zero zero which is the time and
somewhere it's going to say zero packets
and maybes would be right right below it
what's that the graph would be right
below it right I would think so even
though that's not actually what we do
okay so and then here maybe we give at
least the interface en 0 or something
here just as some indication of what
we're recording on to get what I'm
saying what what about the case where
you know for example if you just run
don't specify the interface for network
packet recording it will capture on all
interfaces um what about that case for
network packet capture you just have all
that - probably and somehow yeah just
say I winged it right yeah I like the
idea of specifying all ok ok so there
isn't all setting for network packet
capture ok it's fine so then this is the
thing then what do we think about this
kind of display here
I think it seems choosing to me the
second packets out over time yeah guys
about it this morning whether we should
do a line graph or a bar chart
there's her--they two options I think a
bar chart cuz they're events because
there might be no packets for a while
particularly the filtered packets right
because these are what its gonna show is
but normally the filtered packets and
then the other option is you can also go
downwards like you know like like
packets that are coming in in the
positive direction and packets are going
out in the negative direction okay let's
look at that in a second because the
next question here is do we want to
indicate whether it's filtered because
we're going to be showing
think we're going to need to say
filtered or something like this or
perhaps give the filtering criteria here
if we can now or at least has um you
know I mean now we're coming back in a
circle where yes I know well we're
actually giving the information there
again and I'm kind of saying that we
should because I think otherwise it's
very very very unclear
I'm just concerned about the UI being
very uh novice that this is a record
button because people are used to the
motif of a microphone that's showing
that the bouncing whatever it is right
and that that's a record button
I mean if necessary I suppose we could
label it record or start Billy your
comments do you think we can get away
with kept let me do something which says
start here and not have it be totally
inconsistent with the other things we're
doing they do have a mark over there
which I make it a large button so that
way it's and maybe it's a little bit
heavy-handed but I think that having the
word start or some indication that that
gets you going couldn't hurt
alright well then okay then maybe what
we do is we just say start capture here
and we have essentially a thing which
uses that red motif but has a bigger
button that just says start capture
underneath we have something with its
gray zero zero zero packets okay um and
then
he thought we would have a graph and the
graph if it is heavily filtered there
will simply be a burst of in a
particular bin
you know and then the label of the graph
is basically packets per second isn't it
because those are bins of one second
okay so then the question is incoming
versus outgoing packets
okay system folk how should we show that
um I don't think we should do it with
the outgoing packets being shown as
negative that would be not really it's
not an obviously correct way to do it
the way it's done here is actually not
bad I don't think and I think you're
right that based on the fact that you
might not have some for some period of
time it's probably better not to use a
line graph right but the fact that
they're interspersed like this
I mean is it typically the case that the
amount of incoming and outgoing traffic
is even vaguely balanced I don't think
so I mean it it heavily depends on the
application yeah yeah Chris is right it
it really does depend and all right I
think what we've got right here is it's
not it's not confusing and it really
just depends on the application
so okay all right well then but then
what what Billy is doing there is he's
got color coding um that indicates
packets in and out I mean look the other
thing we could do initially if it's is
just to show total packets per second
and not worry about the in and out it is
interesting to ceiling that but it would
be interesting actually to see what this
would look like if the packets the
graphs the bars are basically stacked on
top of each other instead of overlapping
because that's really when you add them
up that's that's the number of total
packages on the second time right yeah I
think so I think that would be more
useful yeah I sent you a screenshot of
like some other options on your rock a
chat I could see that I mean I know how
to move this over there we go yeah
that's an in/out graph so the Altamont
is the negative axis inbound is I don't
believe in us and then you know you can
stack four different types of traffic as
well
yeah well that's nice being able to
stack being able to color code for
different types of traffic but I mean I
think that's more of a network packet
graphics function that one could do i I
don't let's not put that in this user
interface okay but but what I'm and I
don't really believe in this in and out
thing it's not like an accounting system
is it I mean it's not like it's not like
conservation of packets or something
right guys there's no logical sense
but you might want to know for example
that you're generating a lot of outbound
packets or a lot of you have a lot of
inbound traffic and you're not answering
much of it though those might be useful
things to know whether it's something
important to put here is a separate
question I guess all right well look
okay so our choices are stacked positive
negative or interspersed what do we pick
and we could also imprinted a selector
that chooses between residents
yeah I'm fine for something really
simple for this life thing cuz it you
know there's a lot of overhead in
generating the graph and then you know
have additional network packet graph
functions that can help you you know
really analysis after the fact after
you're done recording that might be good
okay thing that's going to look be the
most useful to have immediately is
there's a stacked bar the that way you
can you can tell which portion of each
second is inbound and outbound but you
can also see relative to the rest of the
graph how it how much traffic there is
that seems to me to be the most useful
thing that you can look okay you can see
it on your Mac if you open your what's
that called on the Mac at the Activity
Monitor Activity Monitor I mean you know
it's very simple even on a Mac like you
know they don't go to your network and
then
howdy oh there we go okay see I mean
that that little picture in the bottom
Center bottom I mean that's all they do
in the MEC like it's very simple you
know positive and negative right they're
doing packets in packet that's what I
was talking about yeah but but there's
no axes no nothing it's just you know
well I note what's interesting here I
didn't think I was running this stupid
retro client thing the what's
interesting here is the way that they're
sorting it by process name oh well we
can't do that no no I don't know it's
just we're just talking about the bottom
part they're the don't know word we have
no capability to distinguish between you
know packets going to a certain process
or not I mean the closest thing you
could get would be port and that's yeah
it's not really yeah it's really the
bottom graph we're discussing like how
to do that we're to do a line graph a
bar chart whether to stack things wanted
to make a distinction between the input
and output order to make distinctions
between you know interfaces you've
selected those sort of thing and how
much you know if we can actually do that
live every second you know well can we
do it live in can we do all right
this is display like the simplest things
we probably can but the more complicated
you make it the you know the simple
display of just a graph you know as long
as it's not updating too quickly it's
fine to do that I mean that's why we
were talking about only updating it once
a second but there are multiple
interfaces involved showing only a
single color for in and out you know
what I think what we should do initially
if we okay if we can show input an
output how we go to color code the input
and output and by the way this doesn't
make any sense this packets in per
second because this is a very you know
ragged line and particularly if it's
been heavily filtered it's incredibly
ragged and to say blah blah blah per
second when there are just two Delta
front you know two spikes basically it
doesn't make a lot of sense
that might be full but it would only be
useful if your link was saturated and
you wanted to get a more accurate count
of how much traffic was right but there
you can get that from somewhere else I
mean you can get that from the yeah um
pretty specific case alright so I think
what we should do is we should just have
a caption it should just say forget it
can say packets per second and then
actually really we want to say I mean we
just need a little blob of color and say
in out and then we show the graph then
the blob of color is just as the caption
to show which part of the thing is
incoming versus outgoing does that make
sense
yeah you can also refresh the design
just to see it's progressing a bit more
but I don't have what you just put down
which one is your oh this one here yeah
I think these have got to be integrated
because that really is a start capture
the whole thing is just to start capture
and I don't think we're gonna have this
pull down here okay
I mean we could do this if we want to I
don't think this per second is gonna
make any sense you've got a grab by the
second I'm not sure I'd be too concerned
about putting the information elsewhere
I mean I what that would be I assume
would be an average per second which you
could always yeah it's just a count
right like you know for one second than
any you you you draw a new line and if
it's in it's in taneous counts it's
gonna bounce all over the place if it's
the sort of time to date you know
packets to date divided by total time
it's going to so I was gonna say if it's
instantaneous that's not gonna make any
sense to have no it's gonna make no
separate it might but it's yeah it's not
that important right okay one advantage
is you having that is that currently we
don't have any label on or don't have
any access label on the y axis of the
graph um
[Music]
right so so I mean that's one event is
if you know you're looking at this graph
it's like okay I see some yeah but like
I mean we could just add a label on the
y-axis right we could we could say this
is really a little a little preview
cartoon thing you know like that it's
not if you really wanted to analysis on
it than you you know sir you sure that
your record I mean like this is a tiny
little here's what we could do we could
have the color swatch thing and then we
could say average : blah blah blah
packets per second okay which is both in
and out okay yeah by average I mean over
the complete recording range right
so so the first the first light color
swatch in an out thing that's just total
packets right if nothing it's just
showing you a color that one's red and
ones whatever oh it's just like a legend
yeah and this is telling you the packets
total packets and this is a little small
thing in grey saying average blah blah
blah packets per second that will update
okay will there be numbers in your
brackets next to in and out or is it
going to be no their colors little color
swatches in fact look at its color the
words in and out if you want to it's
just it's just trying to indicate you
know what's on the what's in the plot
let's see if you can mock that it's
something like this okay and remember
we're removing this so you don't have
this anymore and or we are completely I
think we're completely removing it okay
um okay can we return please okay so I
think that's okay and remember we are
having a pause button well she started
recording we are having a pause button
and we're having an end and capture
button yep there's also a cancel button
if you bring up the interface and just
want to cancel it before you start
recording anything you can press cancel
how do you do that in audio capture the
the stop button is just the cancel
button before you hit oh I see I said
then yep if you hit record then that
turns in
you know I have to say there's a certain
value it seems to me of just having an
icon and I can a graphic thing here
that's just animating back and forth
that indicates network traffic that is
directly analogous to this capture
interface
right I mean this one happens to have
content in it but we could perfectly
well have something which just has a
little thing that is bouncing back and
forth with arrows so network tools do
have in-and-out traffic lights basically
they just blink when they see packets
that well if it's possible to do that
great but we don't want to hang up our
whole system for the sake of doing that
and initially we could simply just have
something directly analogous to this
okay and then we don't have to have the
weird thing that says start capture
because totally obvious
that thing will start you know well and
then we do the mouse over again with
record then we do zero zero on the left
and then we would say blah blah blah
packets on the right okay and then right
below that then we have your color
swatches for in and out and average and
then they graph right yeah when the
graph starts coming up but we don't have
that in the state where you haven't
started recording I guess one other
thing too if you click on the the drop
down for audio capture the the graphic
that's displayed I think you have tape
record for that graph to start getting
something and know how many yeah there
are no labels on that right it's just
purely you know you label this graph
yeah well maybe the right way to do it
is to keep it more iconic and to just
have an arrow up in you know an arrow up
in blue and down in red or something you
see what I'm saying
and forget about showing this average if
or maybe we show the average sort of on
top of the graph on the right hand side
Lily can you try and mark these things I
this is what my favorite would be is to
have something directly analogous to
audio capture and not to try and have
some too elaborate here
back to the design for a minute please
um Billy are you okay trying to mock
that up yeah yeah okay let's go back to
the design where was your design
notebook I lost it
there we go there is okay I don't know
okay
so did by the way do you have
documentation pages for these things yes
okay I mean we could have the full
Association here contain both the time
and the packet number see what I'm
saying and that the whole thing is a
single Association which has port and
time and etc that's true I mean I'm just
thinking for the simple case is like I'm
gonna record for 10 seconds I just I
know I know I know I know it's
definitely what we want but then I
wouldn't record for 10 seconds so what
you would have here if you say I want to
record for 10 seconds and let's actually
try it um
actually let me just try Network packet
recording okay I'm gonna record for 0.1
seconds and what the heck am I getting
here okay
I got 1,800 packets okay so now let's
say I want to record just packets going
out of what I want to record just
Ethernet packets how do I do that so I
have the protocol argument yet the only
things that currently work our
destination ports are a sight for sore
sport IP a destination IP address what's
the difference report mortis both
destination is source is there in the a
port is either the Union mom
yeah the Union yeah interface is
currently is using the old design where
the interface was the but that's we're
gonna change that so that is source or
destination port yes okay so give me a
port number 88 okay
port 80 you probably want to do
something in a web browser okay this is
cool all right I've got to get time web
browser late no not too late no port 80
traffic there was nothing there maybe
HTTP so you gotta go not HTTP it was the
initial request was not secure now you
got upgraded to secure yes if you host
lookup of that destination let's take
this as an example okay because what I'd
really like to be able to do is to say
port goes to HTTP or porch goes to HTTPS
because we do have those traditional
ports right so we have in fact HTTP
should be understood as a network
service brilliant so let's see what
properties we have for that network
service wake up wake up okay look at
that isn't that cool so we should be
able to say I mean to me the following
would be a really nice thing to be able
to do if I could say something like um
here let me let me let me indicate it if
I could do this I mean just to be useful
so to speak if I could say um HTTP or
HTTPS and have that bring me ten seconds
worth of HTTP and HTTPS traffic the
POSIX and BSD system call gets served by
name that does literally what you're
saying there so I'm sure that there's a
reasonable way to do that and it's
probably a good idea so I mean would not
mean go ahead well I would say two
things one the get serve by name yes I
actually wrote eight Wolfram language
wrapper for it that is internal to the
sockets the sockets package so that that
exists and you could use that the other
thing I would say is that for this like
cooked form where you're not specifying
a Association is it most common to want
to specify a service like this I don't
know if that's the most common thing you
want to filter for is this so I don't
know that it's the most common but this
is something that we should support it
is really kind whether it's speaking
just breaking from a networking
standpoint we do want to support this
but I mean as a convenience just say
something like that because CMP is
probably no
yeah I mean they you know we could say
you could say ask for UDP packets and
you could do it this way because I don't
think there's an overlap is there
between service names and protocol names
is there well the entity worst case is
you you know we can have a default for
the string but if you really care you
can use the entity like this thing here
like this network service entity so the
other thing is is that this if we're
using like they get they get served by
name function it could it's looking up a
file like Etsy
I think yes there's se slash services so
that could be customized for you know
and somebody could have some random
reason they have I don't know see him do
this that would be a weird case but they
could in the end if they had been
editing services they probably would be
able to figure that problem out yes true
and that's probably something that you
know they're reasonably aware of what
they're doing ok so ok ok so there's the
default form of if it's not an
association the second argument can
either be a string like you have of a
service name or an entity that is a
network service right I think so I mean
there's also we need entities for
protocols which we don't seem to have so
that's something you need to we'll need
to go to the you know curation folk to
get those in due course you know for UDP
and so on I'm a little confused by this
I didn't know that there even were UDP
ports for HTTP should I know that
HTTP is just another level down from
from like PPP or UDP right that's no I
understand
used UDP to transmit HTTP all right I
mean I don't I don't know of any clients
that would I don't know of any other do
but apparently it's listed in services
that way yeah I mean I just checked mine
and possibly using UDP in the RFC so
what is what is SCTP he said type ours
up next well it's a natural thing but I
can't remember what it is it's something
transport perfectly green control
transmission protocol okay no idea what
it is but I've seen it before also but
okay so let's say that I wanted to
capture CMP packets and I'll do a home
ok and I mean let me just watch that how
would that be done here so I would say
network packet recording and then how
would I say this for the CMP ours so see
it so I mean I think maybe you would say
service as the key goes to I don't know
well this is so this is what it would
look like if you want to run this right
now you'll have to use the port number
and I don't know a port number if you
use it what does ping use I mean ping
that nice ap what's that I was pretty
sure it's ICMP it's like a MP so okay so
what's the port number look it up I'm
sure there is one
[Music]
it is 58 no that's not right
yeah I don't actually see any port
defined for things so it may actually
not use ports how could look how does it
look because I mean so it might be low
enough on the the network stack that it
just it uses the IP address and doesn't
specify a port but I'd have to
double-check how ICMP works I think I
can P is similar to like TCP where it
just makes a connection without without
using a port yes it definitely runs over
IP but it doesn't seem to do anything
protocol you like in terms of ports okay
so then what what I would expect here if
I do let me just try actually running
something okay so what I would like to
do is if this is let's just see how
crazy I am or not
so let's do one
second of recording and I want to do a
ping to that so let's say Network and
soso network packet recording blocks so
you won't get the penny even if it was
going overboard you won't get it oh how
do I do this then so unfortunately the
the way the we were going to do it is
network packet recording submit however
there's some tasks things that weren't
ready for this and I know I should
submit like this well because you you
should probably use local so that
session submit will interrupt the kernel
submit will it will that NPR be set in
the right place it'll be set in the
local cement will start a new kernel and
start running that I think the task
object you get back from local submit
you can use to get the evaluation result
so if you say you know task equals local
submit of just network packet recording
and then yeah I think I think that
should do something and then if you task
of value now there's some property for
task object to get the valuation result
oh it's just called evaluation results
no task is gone I thought it would save
that okay for the for the folks dealing
with task objects let's ask them how to
do this that will be constant in I guess
so I think what you could do is you
could do it with handler functions yawns
that's a mess yeah so so but you're
proposing and shadi what is the analog
of that for audio recording are we
really going to have an audio recording
submit because that's the same thing you
can do it asynchronously I just checked
by the way ICMP does not care about any
port it does not even looked at in the
ICMP header so okay um well
understand then I mean are we going to
have a proliferation of these submit
functions I don't think that would be
neat
no probably one kind of a submit that
then we can do audio submit audio
recording submit Network packet
recording or something like that would
be cleaner yeah I agree but what we've
got so far I mean things like URL submit
huh yeah because because most of these
submit functions yeah they need you know
they need callback functions they need
handler functions because otherwise it's
not clear what they do right guys I mean
if they're asynchronous yeah so actually
under those circumstances I don't know
why we need to submit things at all why
aren't we just doing session submit and
just setting a variable so so the reason
why session submit does not work for a
majority of these cases is because even
if the underlying task is run another
thread session submit blocks the kernel
from evaluating anything else so even if
you didn't submit a pause infinity your
kernel is just blocked forever like you
know even though it's nothing the kernel
isn't actually evaluating anything the
kernels block that's just how session
submit works all right so your claim is
that what we really need to do is a
local submit with a handler function
that says evaluation finished goes to
whatever something like that yes okay
the cleaner way but then it's almost
like we need another kind of generalized
submit function to handle this that
works like session submit but doesn't
block the kernel
I thought session submit had a method
option to not block the colonel an in
session submit is supposed to run into
special time in the colonel which is not
going to work for these because these
have to run in a definite time if you
want packet capture for ten seconds you
don't want it to do that only when you
happen to have an input prompt up right
can you hear me or did I just lose
Network just said my internet is
unstable let's zoom packets you're good
here where are the zoom packets by the
way does anybody know what at what are
the port numbers for zooming good
question 88 or 180 802 okay so here I
could see if I say how do I get multiple
ports here
yeah you you would do it with the list
I haven't hooked that up yet oh we could
she do it with a pattern okay so let's
see and this if I move my cursor around
on the screen it should be sending all
kinds of junk
that's interesting so it comes these are
both incoming and outgoing yeah
what is this as a local host thing right
it's your machine okay
presumably includes audio as well so
that's right incoming outgoing it's not
just you streaming out it's also it's
audio coming it's also using 443 which
is HTTP okay but but this what we're
seeing here what I'm seeing here is the
zoom traffic correct correct
one second of zoom traffic so let's just
use this as an example to actually so
this is relative time so how would I
actually plot this in an interesting way
so let's say I take I'm just gonna use
this as because I want to actually
analyze this a bit does anybody know why
we're still seeing blue in the external
here that's a bug that we've seen for a
week or so I know that think for you
you're seeing that hey I see I see
you mean it's not turning black it's not
something like okay so let's take a look
here at NP all comma a lot of time
and then I guess what we would do
you could look at the differences to see
that's what I was gonna do yeah I was
thinking gaps between packets there it
is so the average gap so if we if we
look at this we can look at histogram
have a looked at this guy's before um
that's interesting cool so that's the
that's I mean that's probably an
exponential type doesn't look that
exponential to me actually but it
probably should be an exponential
distribution so let's that's just for
fun let's look at all packets that came
in over the course of a second and let's
just see what the corresponding results
is I mean again we're just mainly trying
to do this for the sake of just seeing
something definite that we can play with
um so that would be all comma relative
time
now I mean one thing is that you're now
returning in this association all this
stuff including the actual payloads in
and we'll argue that you should be able
to get just this relative time thing
without requesting anything else can you
yeah I mean no right now you just get
the whole dataset returned I don't know
what the design for selecting just part
of that would be a properties thing
I know it should be a properties thing
um oops I want okay um well so let's
talk about
because that does seem useful to be able
to get requests on any parts of that
data set presumably it's much faster to
do that so that would be network packet
recording with a third argument where
the first argument I mean this is what's
getting a little funky here because the
second argument can be quite ornate and
you know the combination of first
argument and second argument I mean
there might be a argument for doing
network packet recording
and then either an association which
gives time packets bla bla bla bla
or as an alternative to that a pure
Oh time or a pure packets hmm see I can
imagine something that would be useful
will be 1 comma HTTP means 1 second
HTTP traffic
or alternatively you could if you really
wanted to say one comma and then the
association so you're suggesting that
the the kind of like filter arguments be
inside a list
I'm not necessarily so I'm saying that
they can be in a single Association or
you can use these sort of shortcut ones
or you can use a combination of the list
and one of the elements of the list
could be a full Association fully
qualified Association that gives
filtering arguments
so but then the first argument is always
specification about the time you know or
the filters or everything about what
you're getting everything about what you
want to capture and the second argument
we built about what you want to return
okay I mean that seems fairly useful
because that way I mean I don't know in
terms of the returns okay so this is a
good example of what we can do here
now what would you like to know can
debugging zoom what would you like to
know here what will be an example
something you'd like to know just to
check whether we can do it so I I mean
one of the things I would like to know
is like if we actually dropped a packet
how many C's I would look at so we would
have to have been recording when it
happened and you didn't see Qin snubbers
right and yeah and we'd have to compare
the sequence numbers of the where is the
sequence number this is well all of
these packets are UDP teasing numbers no
that would be a bit different then yeah
okay so if you wanted to know if we I
mean there's no way to know if you drop
to UDP packet right that's the whole
there's no way to know on these packet
is a really good way so I mean we could
look at the time differences which we've
already done and we see a few gaps so
right I mean that's curious if their
audio UDP packets one would expect them
to be going out and somewhat fixed
sequence meant so we really are we gonna
say this actually brings up a point that
I was gonna mention and that is a lot of
the work that we do in terms of
debugging network things it tends to
involve capturing packets in one spot
and analyzing the capture elsewhere and
I really think we should at some point
support importing and exporting ECAP
files but if we do that excellent so
- that we could probably capture the
packets at the source system and then
later on to see if there are any missing
between points but pcap imported is
there documentation for the pcap
importer I don't remember if we made
well one thing I want to say before I
forget is we support full importing of
pcap files that's that's included with
this and we'll go into 11.3 exporting of
pcap files however is something that
we're not going to do for a levin point
III that's quite a bit more complicated
in terms of like you know the things
that we have in Wolfram language and how
we represent it symbolically and how
that maps to the actual pcap binary
format but setting that aside yeah so so
that's about pcap files I don't remember
if we did let me check and see if we
have format page for UK no we do for how
we do not make that page so that would
be okay so we need that caller than to
chase that yes um and in terms of the
elements for the pcap output they're
going to end up being either data set or
probably the specific labels up here
would that be right yes it does is just
the data set if you want individual
things you have the queries the data set
okay did we agree on this info thing by
the way before you so I guess maybe the
name you might want to change the name
but we agreed on that kind of like
hierarchy of at each level of the packet
right the raw level is just the payload
UDP has some stuff and then TCP has more
like sequence number stuff like that
Ethernet has IP addresses so what why
isn't this like um what should this be
called packet information or something
what should it be called yeah me active
information is just a more verbose form
of info so I'm fine okay fine I mean
that would be more consistent I think
with what we're seeing over here now in
terms of this are these at the same
level Ethernet to IP UDP I mean aren't
these different levels of the network
stack yes the the data set organized it
a little weirdly each info so if you do
like if you take that data set and just
get like the first one it'll make a
little bit more so because it's a list
of associations the the packet
information column is a list of
associations where you know I see that's
the thing that to information that's the
IP information it's UDP mu okay
let's just look at a port can somebody
give me another port that will be fairly
active that invoke there's a TCP port
443 what is that mail what is for
fulfilling age 25 ha okay well let me go
somewhere I'm surprised that's not how
it did this time ago okay all right so
now okay there's this TCP sequence
number what's that
what what does that mean for 4 watts
I went all the way battery though
I'm what are you saying him so what are
we seeing here how do we interpret this
so let's take the first of these packets
on line 53 okay so fine that's all fine
destination port source port destination
port by the way do you think this
ordering is correct source IP address
destination IP address then source port
and destination port or should these be
interspersed
seems like it might make more sense to
put the port right after the source IP
and the destination port right after the
destination IP but although actually
it's kind of nice seeing that these flip
around for for three actually I like it
the way it is oh yeah I don't think it
matters much okay okay all right so this
is what does all this mean TCP sequence
wise what does this mean for total here
so if you can you that yes
so by following the sequence you can
actually it'll actually you can follow
the order of the packets and the order
that they should be received okay so
this is just this is more information
about I don't understand what this is
when says four total oh that's crazy
yeah okay that's because it has the
acknowledged thing at the bottom yep
that's a arguably rather silly
uhm okay it's just because one was
missing that okay I got it
okay and so to get out of this let's
just say I wanted to get the payload of
the first so I would say comma 1 comma
info
well sure I could just
- this one info
and then raw
payload that are and then I would say
normal of that and then I would say for
example normal of that actually
magnificent
useless encrypted so yeah oh it's
encrypted because it support its an HTTP
yeah and this is where you really get
cool is if you knew the keys and you
could just do this all right well it's
just a snippet so that's not gonna
there won't be sequenced correctly okay
all right well I mean so this looks
pretty good
I mean this looks pretty usable um now
what if I wanted a so you can filter by
source port by destination port etc
right yep well you can also thought to
write source IP address destination
um and then there's more keys to those
those are just the ones that I have
working right now well not have the
other Kings what are the kinds of keys
so this that that's the main page for
the PCAT filter so most of most of these
like you know whether it's ipv6 packet
or ipv4 and this list right here
cuz I'm not going to do all of these
because this is just a lot the other
thing it I don't know if we want to talk
you but if you have an order reference
put the MAC addresses in because those
might be really useful at times yeah
okay okay sure I'll make a note of that
the other thing is that internally if if
you know the pcap filter like as a
string as you specify it to like TCP
dump or something like that that that
can also be passed in I'm not sure you
know how to document that when we just
say peek at so I mean why don't we have
a thing be say pcap filter arrow string
is that part of the association then
yeah I think so I don't see what yeah I
mean if we can if I can just pass that a
string in the form of a pcap filter yeah
I'd be pretty happy with that yeah cuz
because clearly what we do is we just
take that symbolic Association and build
the PCAT filter string and then that's
what we'll pass down to the library
that's doing this for us so right you
should publish support a naked rule not
an association just as a courtesy okay
and I think else we need to go over here
we really run way over time um this
looks really close to being what we've
got we whatever if you just one more
time after the changes were made right
let's review another time and look at
final documentation one last thing the
adult actually score all right back up
the dollar sign network packet filter
keys so they are note proposed it's not
an external but what that variable is is
that will just give you a listing of all
of the supported keys that you can put
in that filter Association I'm not
convinced I think that should be
something that's just in the
documentation okay okay well just we can
just put that into that documentation
okay and I find out you just want to
have these I know I know I know I know I
know I know I know that my plan for that
stuff is to put them in the data
repository a bunch of those kinds of
things you know just a small data
repository entries you know possible
filters for this possible musical
instruments for that those kinds of
things all right we need to wrap this
meeting about writing the documentation
but we can do that in the follow-up
documentation okay um all right
practical point shaadi I think your
since you're here oh and actually Billy
if you just had one last if you had some
design that you've been making while
we've been talking we could look at it I
did get a little bit lost with the the
back and forth of the small version that
you were talking about you could refresh
the page and see what I'm kind of
talking about but maybe that's something
I could work with
Ian on which one is it should be the top
one yeah yeah so what we're talking
about is yeah it's it's you should work
with you it's it's more like this okay
okay yeah I got a little bit turned
around so I'll touch base with him fine
do you think that we'd want to maybe go
through time over there I put that as a
question maybe scrub through no it's
it's a to fussy I mean this is this is
not the main event okay maybe in the
future we'll we'll have more
sophisticated stuff here but this is not
the main event this is just a the thing
is alive type type interface okey-dokey
um all right ah great okay so show
I think you're in this next rather brief
meeting about should we just combine
these meetings and just since we have
everybody here except Roger maybe we
could just ask Roger to join this
session and we will change topics here I
think that would be the easiest thing to
do since we don't have very long okay is
Eric here could he get that to happen he
is any other meaning I'll let him know
okay and then everybody who isn't
involved in that subsequent meeting
could leave here
okay thanks a lot guys
thank you yep okay yeah bye I'm gonna
head out my design around I don't
believe we do unless shawty says we do
sorry well what's that
do we need Billy from design here oh no
okay okay
Thank You Billy you later see you have a